there's something you don't bring up in
the book and I think it's a to me anyway
it was a it's a big turn and I don't
know how you feel about it but 9/11
remembered on 9/11
no comedians none of us were on the air
we couldn't be on the air for a while
but you narrated it as it happened in
real time and reacted and I thought of
you as you're not a CNN broadcaster
you're not that kind of broadcaster I
think of you as more of a late-night
comedian I thought Howard's more like
one of us and you were reacting in
real-time to it and your response to
it's incredibly honest and I know that
you've subsequently played it on the
anniversary and it's really powerful and
it's hard to listen to yeah because it's
such a painful day I can't listen to it
but I always thought that that was a
moment where against your will
maybe prematurely maybe you were ready
for it but you didn't want it you were
forced into this situation that you had
to take us all through that day you were
on the air and you did and it sort of
pre I don't it was as it was it was
advanced look at where you were going
does that seem like it's possible it was
a horrible day I'm sitting there on the
air someone comes in and says you got to
put the TV on while I'm on the air I'm
live and I didn't have any thoughts of
like uh you know I was helping anyone
through this or whatever I was Jen in
the moment oh yeah I was in the moment
reacting to what I saw and I immediately
said to Robin the first plane hit I go
this is an act of terrorism in it and
everyone was kind of like no no no you
don't know that you know it could have
been I go to clear day this is an act
and then the second plane hits and then
more and then everyone in the tri-state
area starts calling me people who could
witness what was going on and suddenly I
was real reporters were calling it in
the sense that peep everyday people who
were sitting there were able to report
on their feelings on what was happening
and we all shared this together I felt I
should just sit there we had already
done like a four hour show and I we
we're on the air till then like noon we
did an extra two hours but it didn't
occur to me to leave it just seemed like
the right place for me that I would be
the most useful right and honestly Conan
I was sitting there in shock I was a
jerk and it was really [ __ ] angry
with these goddamn terrorists but what's
amazing is that
that's a document now I mean that is a
document that
I think it's probably one of them for me
one of them were compelling documents I
can't look at the footage of that day I
don't think a lot of us can I still I
lived in New York I was watching it all
unfold from my apartment when it was
that while it was happening I didn't
know how to do with much but your show
that day is a document of
kind of a real-time document of an
honest person's reactions as things are
laid out and because it exists and as I
said reporters can't say the things that
you say you're reacting as a real person
and I always felt like that day and I
think a lot of us felt this way I know a
lot of us felt this way
oh yeah Howard helped us get through
that day you were on the air as it was
happening that was the first time that I
heard you in a different way